foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
and welcome to the audience i'm going to
ask you to bear with me for just a
moment while we
get everything set up
this is crazy
apologize for the delay folks
and
there we are
thank you so much patience everyone and
thank you of itself for joining us today
uh this is a career match class
in building an effective engineering
team
um we have an expert in the subject
avatar aurora here today
and i'm going to introduce her in just a
moment but first
i'd like to introduce the
controls for webex
please answer your questions for avatar
in the q a box we will
be putting those together and
just checking one thing we'll be logging
those
for the q a at the end of the session um
we if you use the chat please address it
to all panelists so that she can see it
otherwise it just comes to me and that's
not as helpful as you might think
um my name by the way is stuart creek
i'm a marketing manager here at simply
learn and i am going to
set up our first poll question we'll
have several poll questions of you and
the audience
and
to do that
first one is a very basic
yes
how much experience do you have in the
audience here
and we'll give you about 30 seconds to
answer that question
if you are
watching on live stream or on youtube
you can put your answers
into the
comments
this is the poll question here
and i will share with you the result
okay
we have a very experienced audience
today um
about half of the
people here responded that they have 10
years more experience
and
we do ask a second question about how
you're doing today because of the
worldwide situation pandemic um good to
see that most people are doing
okay or better than okay and
we hope that this webinar
helps to
improve your outlook so
with that i'm going to introduce avatar
and we'll get started
so uh avatar is a vp of software
development at salesforce and she leads
the development
of several sales cloud products
which are of course
integral to
the success of
salesforce she's led engineering teams
spread management storage operating
systems for application development
and she's been on both sides of
acquisition both as a
acquirer and acquiree in terms of
integrating engineering teams we're very
pleased to have here today welcome
avatar
thank you so much for having me stuart
and simply learn i'm honored to be here
thank you
so uh we can go right into it and ask a
question about
the
effectiveness
of engineering teams what is an
effective engineering team and while
you're
while you're considering that question
i'll queue up the second poll for the
audience
uh you wanted to ask them
what kind of a team they would prefer to
work with
yeah i wanted to hear from folks um can
i hope everyone can hear me okay stuart
there's a little bit of uh delay in your
audio but i hope everyone can hear me
okay
and the reason i post this question as i
you know as i think about effective
teams it you know
what do we think is an effective
engineering team is it one that meets
every commitment that they set out to
that they were asked to do or is it one
that sets these stretch goals sometimes
doesn't meet them but they're trying
very hard what team do you want to work
with so something to consider we'll look
forward to your answers
in my perspective an effective
engineering team is one that actually
understands how their work fits into the
larger company strategy
and then is willing to switch gears when
the business needs right whether whether
you're not a startup or a big company
responding to changing market trends is
one of the biggest competitive
advantages and that sometimes decides
you know it's the difference between
winning and not winning i won't say
losing but winning and not winning
and the other part of an effective
engineering team is
whether you're a rockstar engineer or
you're a 10x engineer or whatever else
happens right
um an effective team is one that
actually works together to get things
done together
right and i'm very pleased to see the
results of the poll which says you know
team stretch sets these stretch goals
and doesn't sometimes may not meet them
but they're working very hard to meet
them and i think i think the point
really here is that an effective
engineering team understands the why uh
they know that some goals are sacred and
then they cannot be missed right if
we've committed something to a board or
something to a customer those really
should not be missed but they're also
adaptable they're looking at these
market trends and they're saving some
buffer for innovation and for stretch
goals so that when we have the
opportunity we can get to them
but about these stretch goals i mean
it's great to have them but it's super
important to communicate
uh about what's happening right left
right up down whichever direction it's
very important to communicate how these
stretch goals are going and then
the last but not the least as we're
working towards these sacred goals or
these stretch goals we're working
together as a team
and we're working you know as a team
which is in interdependent on each other
that's also very important for an
effective engineering team
okay
um
one of the
greatest things about the
era we live in is
how quickly things change so
uh
how does effectiveness
relate to agility and the ability to
pivot to new priorities new projects or
new products
absolutely that that is a center center
piece of effectiveness right so let's
say we're working on this product and we
see the market change i mean kovit the
pandemic has taught us so many things
right so many teams were working on a
set pattern i'll give you my own
experience we at salesforce you know are
part of sales cloud and our goal is to
make sales people more productive and we
do this with various tools and products
and as the pandemic hit us we realized
that
every sales rep is no longer like you
know their sales reps are known to go
out meet people go dining wine
you know and all of that became
impossible with the pandemic and every
rep became an inside sales rep and hence
conducting effective meetings
on zoom or webex or whatever other tool
became the most important things that we
quickly had to pivot to change our
products around slightly to make sure
that we were addressing that need so i
think as i was saying that is the most
important thing for a team to be able to
recognize their goals and be and pivot
as and when needed
okay
um and you you talked about
interdependence and the ability of
team members to work
together but we also talked about how
team members need to be independent self
starters
um
you know responsible for their own
productivity how do those two
dynamics
yeah that's a i'm glad you picked up on
that to it that's a great point because
you know especially when we're early in
our careers we're trying to focus on how
to become independent right uh the good
the good team member is one who can
independently get things done and that's
sort of the first um first mark of okay
you've been successful in your first
engineering role
but as you grow you realize that it's
not just about what you do right um like
i may start a company on my own i may
build test deploy i've got this app
going great you know eventually
very few companies are one people
companies right so now i decide i want
to build a small team
um and of course i'm thinking about the
top talent i want to hire really smart
people and now i've got a few people and
very quickly their roles start to emerge
right somebody is really good at
deployment somebody's very good at the
front end somebody is really solid that
you know the the file systems piece
and soon you know if you're doing well
hopefully you're expanding that
out into teams of these specialties
there's a front-end team and a back-end
team
and now the key thing here the
difference between
winning and losing is actually
how these teams work well together
regardless of the team size whether
you're you know small teams or large how
these teams trust one another foster
true teamwork where they're not about to
like throw things over the wall but when
you're building the culture of building
things together is super important in in
an effective team
i'm asking the audience by the way i see
the connections
can you hear me
speaking
if you put in the chat
because i i i know that avatar is
hearing the questions i'm asking yeah
we're seeing that
subcampus cannot okay
stuart your audio is a little uh
it's it's yeah
i apologize i apologize for that and
i'm not sure how to fix that
but
let's just go on
um
so
we talk about
culture you know when you when you
mention building a team
now you have the interactions of people
with one another
and
by definition that creates a culture
so the the the slogan
culture eats strategy for breakfast
uh
tells us how much things have changed in
business thinking
and and why we put emphasis on it but
how do we know if
the culture that we have is the right
one for for our business
and you know what how would we know that
it's right you know what
what are the metrics the parameters we
decide
a culture which makes
yeah it's a great it's a great question
and you know it this is
we're talking about effective teams you
know the same questions asked of
effective companies right
so
this is one of those million dollar
questions like you said stuart that
hasn't doesn't have a great like it
hasn't doesn't have one answer right uh
ultimately i'll say
the teams usually have a culture and
that culture is throughout the
organization you know it's the job of
leadership to make sure that culture is
pervasive throughout the organization
and for example facebook is known for
you know build fast and break things
and that ultimately if you believe in
that that ultimately helps you decide
when you're having to make a big
decision about should i do x or y that
cultural tenet helps you decide which
way to go and you know over time they've
obviously changed that but like there
are key things you know customer
importance uh importance of innovation
importance of moving fast importance of
security and availability those those
things are culturally you know set from
the top which is great
i've i've learned that as leaders
whether you're an architect or an
engineering manager or a vp or a leader
you have to absorb and figure out what
is unique about your team yes you follow
the company's cultural tenets obviously
how do you build that uniqueness in your
team and for me at least i felt like
there's three or four things that i
value the most and i try to make
pervasive across my team
number one for me is psychological
safety
we talked about you know this is an
effective team
um for a team to work together they've
got to be able to count on each other
they've got to be able to take a few
risks
and it's okay to fail they've got to be
able to reach out across to their team
and say hey i'm thinking about this this
is not necessarily the right part how do
we you know help me work through this
they should be able to be vulnerable and
admit that they don't know and they want
to learn right so having that
psychological safety
building that trust i think is number
one across a team
an equally important thing is valuing
diversity
and you know we talk about a you know we
talk about gender and race as the topics
of diversity most of the time but it's
not just that right it's age it's
background it's diversity of thoughts
its
its valuing and listening to every
member on the team and making sure that
input is counted um because that's
actually what makes teams better
uh the third thing i really value is
strong ownership um just last night
actually we had a production issue
and you know an engineer pinged me
because they needed some approvals and
you know we got on a call and over the
course of the two hours that we were on
the call three other engineers joined to
help us all figure all of this out it
was a pretty complex problem
and
three of the four engineers on the call
had nothing to do with the code like
they had not written that code they had
they were not part of it but they joined
because they felt like they had
knowledge of the product and how this
could impact other pieces
and you know we got it figured out late
at night we've got it solved it's all
good
the point that sticks with me and i want
to bring up now is that ownership right
which is
yes i wrote the code so i'm going to go
figure this out but also yeah i didn't
write this code but this impacts an area
or i have the opportunity to influence
something where oh i know about this
area so i'm going to jump in and help no
matter what you know uh who wrote it
there's no there's no blame actually
all you know we talked about it we've
got the fix in i still don't know
actually who wrote the code you know
it's not the engineer who brought it to
my attention and that's the part that's
you know not important it's not
important who wrote it it's that
ownership across the team of we're going
to make this right for our customers
right so that is super important
and last but not the least i think the
the thing that's important about the
culture is the culture of continuous
learning you know we all make mistakes
how do we learn how do we come out of
that stronger and not make that same
mistake again there'll be a different
mistake we'll make again so
you know for me it's four things it's
psychological safety diversity and
valuing it truly valuing it
ownership and continuous learning i
think those make a very very strong
culture for and for a for an engineering
team right
i think
psychological safety is is one of the
big
trends
that emerged i think in the last couple
of decades and the culture of no blame
is so important in an engineering
environment
um it actually came out of aviation um
if you're aware of that
because
it was
from root cause analysis air like
crashes
that
the principle of
let's let's fight cause not assigned
blame
became important and it's pervaded
health care where no blame is a
tentative of uh
health care delivery and nursing and
as you mentioned in engineering so
but the notion the example you used of a
team coming together to solve a problem
um
he had people contributing whether they
were the author of the problem
or just had the expertise to solve it
that's a great model for an engineering
uh
indian
people cooperating
and continuous learning is
also
very near and dear to the hearts of us
here at simplyland um
so we want to go out to the next
question which is what are some of the
metrics of effectiveness
and
i'm going to
um put up that
as coal
so if you'll
bear with me i'll pull
while you're starting the poll uh
steward if i may i'll take one of the
questions that i'm seeing in the q a um
in the chat and that is to make an
engineering team effective you said we
should understand the needs and
expectations of current demands but top
management has the ultimate authority to
set up the strategies
what if i'm not good enough so despite
good enough understanding consumers what
if i'm not good good enough to convey
the information to top management what
should i do
uh it's questions from gotham great it's
a really solid question gotham because
you're right like sometimes we don't
have the access we need to the top
management um
and i think the best thing you can do in
that case i i would recommend two things
one i found
that sometimes you know putting together
a little demo or a hackathon kind of
thing which you put together and show
right because slides and words and
documents will convey things but
sometimes if you show something saying
here's the problem here's a creative way
to solve it i think that has an impact
and of course you know you'll have to
take it up the levels of your chain but
i think that has a really solid impact
of showing and the other is actually
working you know you're an engineer
working with your product management or
basically your peers who are helping
convey that strategy convey that right
again make a solid
whatever is your best mode of
communication document powerpoint um or
a demo and take that to your product
managers and explain how uh and get some
partnership on that take it to your
manager like take it to people who may
have more influence in the organization
than you would would be my best advice
and stuart we'll go to your uh we'll go
to your poll yep
and here is the result pulled
so because there were more than one
answer allowed
um it adds up more than 100 but team
velocity was the
one that was
chosen by most people
people
so again this is a great question
because you can see
the reason for this question really is
uh
that as an engineering
leader and as a
there are many many different things
that we can do for effectiveness like
what do you want from your engineering
leader can be multiple things
and ultimately
your engineering
the engineering leader has to put on
different hats at different times
whether you're an architect or a people
manager
you should know what your team needs
from you and this poll was very
illustrative of
a certain team
may need a certain thing and another may
need something completely different so
number one you should be able to wear
those different hats
and if you can't you should be aware
enough that maybe this is the hat i
cannot wear so i'm going to very clearly
ask someone else to play this role
right i'm going to either delegate that
or ask for help
but
number one understanding
what the team needs
and then executing to that is a huge
huge part of what an engineering leader
does
that's a
general
model of a sprint leader right somebody
who who
takes the position of leadership from
the perspective of
what can i do to help my team succeed
so
that's an
important aspect of the of the
philosophy of leadership
yeah
sorry stuart i can say a little bit more
on that right so i've been in situations
i'll give you an example where there was
one time we had you know in this
acquisition and you know the team had
the team had a react native app
uh and the acquired team had a full
native app built on java and swift right
and the discussion was where do we go
from here and we had to make a technical
decision we spent a lot of time
discussing this
and figuring out the answer right
um so there was that time needed solid
technical leadership
that's what it needed we got it done
uh there's been other times where it's
been about process and so i guess i
would argue i would argue that an
engineering leader be it a technique
like an architect or a people leader
really the biggest job you do is to
build engagement so let me let me talk
about this a little bit what does
engagement look like
um
i'll give you an example instead of just
talking so this was a time when i was at
a company where we were building a
startup within a big company
we were competing with a lot of other
startups we had a lot of pressure
and we were hiring
very very quickly
and so we had to figure out who to hire
and whether people we hired were happy
or not and so we decided we had taken
some training and this book i'd
recommend to anybody who's thinking
about leadership and engineering it's
called love them or lose them and then
there's another one called stay
interviews and the summary of it is that
you can hire really quickly but if you
can't retain talent then you have a
really huge problem right and
engineering skills are in high demand so
you can hire uh and you unless you know
what motivates each person you're not
going to be able to retain them for long
so we did this thing that we called stay
interviews which was with each person
the question was
what are your top motivating factors
and how are we doing
towards those factors
so let's say the factor is
money
and i want to get promoted career growth
and i want you know a good work-life
balance because you know right now my
work-life balance is not great so those
are my top motivating factors this is
what keeps me in a job and money you
know you're paying me okay it's fine but
really i'm looking for career growth
right now
or that i um you know i i feel like
we're not meeting customer demand so
whatever right we got all of this
feedback
and from that we were able to assess
where the team was and where we needed
to you know were there some really
overall systemic problems like were we
seeing career growth as a systemic
problem that we needed to address or
uh was money a systemic problem and then
the you know what are the individual uh
issues we needed to rest so we actually
got a lot of data out of this
and i'll summarize this by saying that
we find and there's a lot of research on
this that there's three things at a high
level that motivate people it's rewards
you know it could be economic incentives
which is you know just pure money but it
could also be things like you know what
am i learning uh what am i getting done
like getting things done is a big big
motivator for people and you know this
team moves too slowly they don't get
things done we're not moving blockers
fast enough so that's an incentive
the second key high level area is
respect which is you know we talked
about psychological safety we talked
about taking risks but do people feel
like they're getting the respect are
they able to connect with customers and
show people what they've done and get
that industry-wide expect respect
in a community to say this person is the
expert at react native for instance
right so it's just
the building that you are the person and
then you know building that respect
among people and the third thing is the
sense of purpose which says you know a
sense of ownership how does my work fit
into the larger whole
how do we decide where we're going
and you know yesterday you made the
decision about react native or full
native how do i take that on so how do i
grow such that tomorrow i'm the person
taking on that um responsibility of
making that decision so at those three
levels if you recognize what people need
and if you're able to make that happen
for your larger team individually and
your larger team that starts to build an
effective team that starts to build
engagement in your team
um it's
very interesting because people uh you
know the
psychology
model is maslow's hierarchy of needs
and we go from the very bottom which is
you need to have food and shelter and
physical security
to the very top which is factualization
which gets the point that you're making
of
if i'm doing work as part of a team
is the team accomplishing something that
i can then point to and say i was part
of that
and
will i be able to make that claim that
says
i was part of that and i have a an
ownership of that
that great result that came out of it so
those are
motivating factors but i
really like the idea of the stay
interview
of
an ongoing temperature gauge of
what are we
doing well and not well as group as an
organization
in order to meet
your needs as
an engineer especially in a time when
um engineering talent is still it's
premium
you talked about
well we talked about the different
metrics
can you
go into a little more about how you
balance those because i pointed out one
of them as oh this is one that most
people look at but
you put up you know
the set metrics for a reason
yeah
um
and sorry we mixed up these questions
sorry story i couldn't hear you very
clearly
the question is
you know how do you balance the
importance of
metrics because you can't just pick one
and
focus on it exclusively
absolutely so absolutely agree so so
coming in metrics right um you know
first things first i'll say that
you know we're engineers we'll find a
way to outstart uh outsmart any metric
that you put in front of us right um if
you measure me by how many story points
i get done i'll start ignoring the bugs
if you start story pointing the bugs
i'll spend less time on one you know
mentoring engineers junior engineers or
spending less time on peer review so i
can focus on the story points and the
bug points right
uh if you compare one team versus
another based on just team velocity
we'll start inflating inflating story
points and then we'll have higher
velocity so i've often found that
looking at any of these individual
metrics and then rewarding people based
on those metrics i find that results in
long-term in bad behavior
effective teams according to me set
outcomes i mean we set goals based on
outcomes and deliverables and overall
results not just the amount of work
being done right so i personally don't
look at velocity so yeah sure we we
track these metrics
but ultimately we don't look at velocity
i don't look at velocity just for
execution but i look at velocity for
overall
how is the team doing so for instance
is this team consistently you know a
pull request taking too long
and upon requesting full requests taking
too long to be reviewed uh because
people are overwhelmed and they don't
have time
or are these pr's too complex and you
know we just need to have a culture of
making the the pr pr smaller so that
people can make the time to review them
uh are the automated tests failing too
much due to flakiness and
is that the problem that's causing other
problems right uh how often is master
red or you know is a team locked out we
have this concept of if you don't have
any open security bugs the team is
locked out from making any aprs because
uh i'm sorry any check-ins because we
want to get those security defects
addressed first so
is the team often locked out or is
master off in red
and are we addressing the underlying
cause um so that we get becoming more
effective
are we going back and forth on
requirements with pm and ux
because we're not getting requirements
clearly and we're not doing sort of a
definition of ready before we start
actually executing we just start
executing and then we go back and forth
and back and forth so measure that uh
how much code is being written rewritten
and refactored
right
uh one other metric we look at is what
is the ratio of tech debt to innovation
release over release
so
you know every team over time will you
know we will accumulate some tech debt
but is that changing to the point that
we're doing way too much tech debt and
not enough innovation or vice versa so
we're not paying attention to to both
sides you know of the house
um these are super important metrics
that you know you can look at them as a
whole and actually start to make
difference a difference
one other metric that i know will seem a
little
may seem surprising is happiness and
well-being
is the team
does the team enjoy working together do
they make time for casual conversations
is this a team because they like to work
together will they stick through thick
and thin
or is this a you know transactional team
that just you know and that's that's
okay that may be okay for a short amount
of time but really um how and how do you
measure that by the way um again many
ways to do it one way is simply during
your sprint you know end of sprint just
do a quick poll just like you do story
pointing you know one two five however
people do story pointing do a quick poll
how are things going and you will start
to get a sense of the team
um you know is not very happy together
what do we what do we do about that
so i look at these kinds of metrics
velocity not just for
sprint execution but velocity of overall
our cycle time overall tech debt and
happiness i think those metrics really
make a difference in team effectiveness
yeah and
happiness is not such a surprising or
unusual metric
because
a team that
doesn't work together
smoothly
is not going to accomplish
nearly as much or with nearly as high
quality as a group of people
who enjoy working together and enjoy
helping each other so it's it's a very
important metric
uh
so i'm going to bring up
a more pool
this is the last one before we
uh
in this part of the discussion
and this is when you wanted to ask the
audience about what they want from their
engineering leader
so if
what is the one thing
pick one of these five that you would
want your engineering leader to give you
right now
avital made this be a single answer
question to force make a
priority choice
yeah i really wanted to get a sense for
how like how does this audience what
does this audience think
and here's the result
the results are pretty interesting not
surprising
um
and i think the the the thought i'd have
here is
does your engineering leader know that
right and they need to be asking you
this question so so this is actually
illustrative of as an engineering leader
what should we be doing
but so many times
again as managers or architects we're
running around trying to solve a problem
where we may be saying uh you know um i
think there's there's a problem here we
need to add more people because you know
there's not enough people on the team
but in reality the team is saying
there's lots of cross team blockers it's
not like i have enough people on the
team but we have these cross team
dependencies that are not getting met
and just remove these blockers and then
we'll be okay
or the team is saying i you know i have
the people but we are struggling with
decisions about which way to go
architecturally and what we need is
really technical guidance right and you
saw you saw that in the results i hope
everyone saw that there was a pretty
good split between i thought technical
guidance removed across teamworker and
feedback about how i'm doing
and
to be an effective leader
the point i'm trying to say he
illustrate here was
different teams need different things at
different times the number one thing you
can do as a leader is ask the question
is what can i do for you today this week
this month
and then help solve that problem
because if you don't you could be
running up around something doing
something completely different
okay
um and that that makes
perfect sense in the sense that
if you don't know
to ask about what potential problems
there are you'll never see the problem
you'll never be able to solve the
problem and you'll get blindsided when
somebody comes to you and says
i'm leaving because you never did this
and
your
thought will be
but you never ask me
so
um but it's but it's the leader's job to
ask right don't wait
ask
exactly exactly um
so
what do you see as the role of an
engineering leader
what is what is if you're going to
summarize it
how would you
create the job description for the
engineering league here
i i'll say it i'll summarize it very
quickly because we've talked about this
through the through the talk i don't
want to repeat but it's two things right
ask what the team needs and figure out
how to solve that either yourself or by
getting in help right if you don't know
how to solve these cross team blockers
get in somebody who can ask your manager
for help if you can so number one figure
out what the team needs and number two
drive the engagement in the team so that
the team is working together the team
has what they need uh to be successful
um
so
when we talk about building a team
there's the initial assembly
as you talk about your example of so i'm
the one-person startup but i need to
have people help me
to
achieve launch
but then what happens when you scale up
when you double you triple you raise by
a factor of 10
yeah
you know there's entire books written on
scaling so stuart i'm certainly not
going to be able you know
can have a whole discussion on that i
think you know the first thing is you
know
congratulations whatever you've been
doing it's been recognized by your
leaders your customers and now they want
you to do more of it so take a minute to
pat yourself and your current team on
the back and say hey we're
growing and that's an awesome thing
right
and then right
right behind that recognize that what
got you here would get you to your next
goal right and start formulating a plan
for this growth
i learned this you know again i was
building this startup within a big
company and we were 18 people when in
the beginning and we used to have this
really good process of we used to meet
you know two times a week we get
together with pizza we talk about
technical decisions decisions that were
pending the ones that were made
communicated made sure everybody knew
what was going on and then off we went
and two days later we got back together
did the same thing it was great and we
moved really quickly
and we found that literally when we got
from 18 to 30 that same thing didn't
work anymore right because uh people in
the back of the room couldn't hear
somebody didn't like the pizza so they
want to get their own lunch and so they
missed the meeting i mean for good
reasons and all kinds of reasons
uh they didn't scale that there wasn't a
need for 30 people to be in that same
room uh at the same time making
decisions 30 people didn't need to make
that decision and so we started to you
know break the team down into smaller
chunks and say okay this team is
responsible like you know accountability
for each area and we found that that
made people a little bit mad because you
know these folks who were used to being
in every decision now weren't and they
felt disempowered and that was horrible
that was not the intention at all right
and so we i quickly learned that a big
big part of
leadership and effective leadership in
teams is communication
which is how do you create a process
for
code reviews for
technical decisions for
hiring who are you trying to hire how do
you make sure that skills because what
worked for 18 doesn't work for 30 does
not work for 100 and certainly doesn't
work for 200 right so how do you scale
that and how do you communicate that
clearly how do you decide that the
hiring process should be the same for
this set of 30 people and then this
other set of 50 people maybe it
shouldn't right
but two things there
be purposeful don't don't let this
happen to you figure out what the
problem is and get ahead of it and you
know be purposeful about what you're
doing
and equally important actually i'd say
more important communicate that
communicate communicate to what the
problem was
why you solve like how you solved it and
what you know what you're doing to solve
it and why those decisions were made
clear communication is key during
scaling
yeah
we have the the management
principle of span of control
and when you talk about
how many people an individual can lead
at once
directly
um
you have to start saying well we get
past that point you have to find ways to
lead them indirectly
and so you talk as you said breaking
teams groups
but how do you
make sure
that the message
translates
both going down from the top to all the
groups and coming up from the groups
back to the top
community you know channels of
communication
and making sure people have
ways to feel heard
and
understand
why their input was either taken
or rejected
but it was always heard and that's those
are all
very very important
aspects
um
so for a company that is
you know in the in the mode of hiring
right and left because they're growing
rate
what are the common mistakes
that's a
that's a great question um i'll tell you
all the mistakes i've made
um
lots of them right
i think
the biggest mistake i think is if you
hire people just like you right it's
very easy for us to you know we've got
this mold of what's you know what's made
me successful so you know just hire
people just like me and we don't we
don't do this consciously i'm not saying
i'm looking for this
but unconsciously it's very easy to hire
people just like us
um you know very classic example of this
which you know has nothing to do with
race or gender or anything else is um
you know long ago google uh when they
built the ios youtube app
they uh found that when they first
released it they found that a lot of
videos were being posted upside down
they were confused like why would people
post upside down videos it makes no
sense
and they realized and they've done a lot
of testing they said they didn't know
what's going on but after a lot of
debugging they found that
uh
left-handed people were basically
because
the person's view of the landscape is
you know the other way they just hadn't
tested that and all these videos showed
up upside down and you know what this
tells you is they didn't have any
left-handed people in their development
or qa team
now
the point here is actually very simple
which is you need
diversity on your team and hiring people
just like you won't
won't be the best answer now i'm you
know hiding left-handed people
right-handed there's tons of kinds of
diversity so this is a very creative
example to show that again diversity
should be top of mind while hiring
uh i think the so that's number one just
starting with number one is diversity
um the other mistake that we often make
is we don't set clear expectations right
when we hire somebody where you know in
this cell mode we're telling them here's
what you can do here's how you can grow
great right but when a person joins they
need to know what is their 90-day goal
and oftentimes this gets lost in the
larger goals and i think setting the
very very clear expectation of what a
success look like helps people succeed
quickly
the opposite of this is by the way also
very true and is a common mistake we
made wise make while scaling
which is sometimes we're too
prescriptive we say well here is exactly
what we want you or the team to do and
that is also a problem because we don't
empower people enough then right you put
them in a corner you say here's what you
go solve and then they're waiting for
that next problem to be solved
um so i think
you've got to find the balance between
giving people to your goals but not
being too prescriptive you know you have
to find the right balance when you hire
people in a new team
the other thing the other thing is sorry
okay the other thing is um you know we
talk often about a netflix has this
whole culture deck they do right where
you don't want to hire brilliant jerks
and i think this is super important
because if you hire somebody
but they're not a team player
uh we talked about you know independent
interdependence and team building a team
and if you have people who are really
smart but are not willing to work as a
team that causes problems so
don't best thing is figure out whether
this person is a team player you know
through your interview process
and
and the last thing uh the last thing
i'll say is you know the big mistake you
can make is if you ignore attrition if
you you know you do exit interviews and
you'll say well why did this person
leave what can we fix but why not do the
stay interviews that i talked about
earlier why not figure out what
motivates people so you can retain the
people uh instead of you know letting
them go and having to replace
them you touch a
number of great points especially
since i'm left-handed i especially
interpret the youtube example um
but
the other one that brings
true with me is about
not hiring
brilliant jerks because i've worked in a
number of situations where
there's that one guy
who does
something really really really well
and
you have to ask yourself
is it really worth the amount of
friction he creates
the rest of the teams
that's a that's a
really important point um
when you look at the organism i think
this will be the last question before we
get to
q a but
when you look at organization structure
how do we decide what is the right way
to organize
an engineering team
yeah this is often debated and debated
in organization small and large steward
and i've been part of these debates
myself um and i again there's not a
great answer but there's two very strong
things to consider right
sometimes what you do is form a team
around a product where the product is
key so especially after your product
market fit you're in a small company
large you have product market fit you
know this is the product you want to
build
you go organize a team around a product
and give that team ownership of that
product and say go build this thing
right and then you hire people around
that product
uh the other way to do it is um
more common in companies trying to do a
lot of innovation ground up smaller
companies
it's
uh around hiring around people like you
have
not brilliant jerks but
people who are actually good team
players but team players but you hire
around these people and these people
will go pivot like they will go from one
project to the other this set of people
will be able to accomplish amazing
things right and so they become like
what we call the sniper team where
anytime there's something
really hard to go solve you go get them
to start solving it and they will figure
it out and i think organization
structures work best when they blend the
two right consider both blend the two
have a little bit of both i feel like
that's the best
yeah that makes sense
i i've heard other terms from the sniper
team like the
the sky quirks the the [ __ ] that
type of thing but yeah the
flying squad of experts
is
important to have but
they're the people who fix things rather
than
get the bulk of the work done so
like you said it's important to balance
that um we're at the point where i'd
like to ask some of the questions from
the audience
um
do you want me do you want me to go
through them stewart myself or did you
want to uh go through
i'll i'll go through because we won't
have time to do all of them and i want
to make sure that we capture a few of
them we do have
one question
about
somebody who's
a developer a very skilled developer um
is that somebody who could translate
this particular question is whether he
could trans for those skills to ethical
hacking
yeah
absolutely
there are so many companies including
uh where i'm at now like lots of
companies that have security teams that
actually want to hack their own products
as a way of preventing that hacking
coming from outside right so ethical
hacking is absolutely a thing now where
we call them the red team the blue team
you know we have these different teams
and i'll tell you how we do it um we
actually have teams that will put
together these security these hacks that
they are going to deploy against all of
us as
employees and they want to see which of
them work which don't which is in our
code but it's also which is in our
behavior because a lot of security hacks
today happen not necessarily in code but
it's just fishing and human behavioral
uh impacts right and so there are teams
that will have these teams that are
hidden but their job is absolutely uh
ethical hacking go for it very very high
highly uh sought after skill right now
excellent
um we have a question from hari uh and
i'm gonna paraphrase this question a
little bit
but he asks
uh
how do you get a team to self-organize
into the agile environment
uh if the resisting change and
seeking to fight
waste blame other
causes for not taking this up how do you
manage that kind of cultural
transition
yeah i i think you know if i were a
manager or a scrum master of this team i
would really dig in to find out is the
larger team resisting
some change or is this an individual and
usually you know i like to think of a
team not an individual but sometimes in
problems such as these you want to know
is there systemically something where
the team is saying look here's you know
we used to do things over six months and
this was our process and now we're
trying to get me to convert into these
two weeks and it won't work because
where is it a team thing or an
individual thing and then you address it
accordingly
if it's a team
by the way some of these concerns are
bound to be genuine they're not they're
not frivolous i mean these are all smart
people so it is about sitting down with
the team and again it you know to me
it's going back to the why right why are
we trying to do this transformation how
does that tie into the business goals
and
how do these teams then feel like you
know
make the bridge right
we want to make this transition the team
is resisting it
list out just like your root cause
analysis we talked about right what are
the issues and let's address each of
them
each of them right let's not ignore them
and on the other side maybe there's one
person who's not brought in and sort of
is being the bad apple and influencing
the rest and then you know there are
ways to address that maybe
many ways to address that one for
individual but i think just again
digging into team versus individual is
super important in something like this
um
javier asked for clarification on what
psychological safety needs
great question
psychological safety is
the ability for someone to be themselves
to be vulnerable to take the risks
to succeed regardless of basically you
know there's no wrong or right right
when you're an engineer on a team you
are a team member just not necessarily
just an engineer a team member
you are part of this larger organization
that is trying to achieve a goal
how do you put yourself out there be
yourself who you are and succeed
right uh without worrying about where
you come from what your background may
be what your age may be gender
just
feel safe to do your best
so
what is the one
question
the most effective question that you can
ask your team
to gauge their progress
one question to gauge their progress
yeah what's the most effective question
i would ask the team
are you where
you expected to be
and are you where you wanted to be
um
because expected is
you know again there's an expected goal
but wanted will also imply did you hit
your stretch goal
so sorry it's not one question it's sort
of one and a half
teams you know how do they gauge their
own progress because you know the team
is usually the hardest critic of
themselves usually
okay
um
so
here are a couple of related questions
alpha asks
can you give insights on the way to find
team members strengths weaknesses
and how to address those so that you
fix weaknesses
yeah we've done this in the past in two
ways right one is to get the team to
actually self-assess first
individuals you know and this is soft
skills and technical skills both you can
you can do the same exercise for both
which is do a self-assessment
right
and then do a peer assessment and your
peer assessment is always anonymous i'm
not saying stuart said avital is really
bad at excellence that's not what we're
trying to do at all
just kidding i'm just picking a news to
it because i can there's nobody else to
pick on i can't see anyone else
uh but but really it's about
and that tells you you know self what do
i think what do you think and again the
anonymous ceo should be across multiple
people not just one-on-one and then you
do us you know it's a it's data driven
and you have that conversation
okay
and and aside from technical performance
which is sometimes even it's subjective
what are the other ways you assess
uh
whether a person's a
good developer and a good fit for the
team
a lot of the things in this are going to
be repeats of what i said because you
know i espoused through this last 50
minutes or so i've been saying nothing's
important to me which is
does this person you know value others
opinion does this person listen you know
is it just the loudest opinion or you
know can does this person listen to
other people uh do they um do they
foster a team environment is it just
them or are they actually looking at
their team's success as well
do they have strong ownership when
something goes wrong whether they did it
or not or who doesn't matter are they
there to help support the team and make
sure the team is successful
those to me are key tenets of is this
person
a good developer
a strong being a strong team player is
part of that being a good developer
uh
here's an interesting question from
petite who asks
what percent of the percentage of your
bandwidth is
guidance and upskilling and
paying attention to making your team
future ready
or do you find that that usually just
happens when
some kind of big
technological trend changes and you have
to scramble to adjust it
no i i spend a lot of my time on the
future readiness i feel like my job is
my job is to build a team that can
self-execute
and myself execute i don't mean kill
themselves i can they can just execute
flawlessly to the goal right my job is
always a hundred percent looking at
what's coming in the future
and how is my team getting ready towards
that which means are we training
uh technically but also just knowledge
of the product sometimes knowing and
understanding the business is as
important as understanding the
technology i would argue that you can go
to a week-long training and learn a new
technology but understanding and looking
at market trends has to happen over time
so 100 of my job is
figuring out where we are going from
here and making sure we're getting ready
for that
because but i've been able to do that
because i i've been able to build a team
that is very self-driven
um
before i forget we have a question about
which books you mentioned
oh
there's a couple of other resources i
meant to talk about so the books i
talked about were the stay interviews
and love them or lose them and stuart i
can send you links to them that you can
send out maybe but another resource i
wanted to point people to is molly
graham's
uh it's called giving away your legos i
didn't get a chance to talk about it but
i think that's a wonderful article that
talks about scaling and about just
making sure your team has empowerment to
go grow so i would also recommend that
another book that i didn't talk about is
seven habits of highly effective people
i would you know definitely uh read that
it's you know key there you know seek to
understand before you want to be
understood like anyway these are really
really good books to read okay
yeah i uh we
sent out a follow-up email um
generally the next day after the event
and that includes the link to this
recording of this event but if you send
me the the links those books articles
and events i'll put that in the
absolutely appreciate that uh
i think we are
uh running out of time i want to ask one
last question
that has to do with
managing upward when
two questions that came in that are
related one
about
you know senior management thinks that
they can motivate engineers with money
um and yet they don't necessarily give
engineering leaders the
authority to
set salaries
um and the other one is about
you know if there's a blocker on a
different team and management
you've appealed the management say i
need you to help me address that
and they're not
taking action so
both of these questions have to do with
how do you manage
upward within your organization
yeah both of these
have answers that can get people into
trouble so use it your own discretion
uh i tend to find that you know when
it's about um team blockers i tend to
find that highlighting those things in
whatever level executive reviews there
are gets me a lot of attention and
sometimes it gets me into trouble too
but you know there's a time where you
just have to escalate you got to put
your neck on the line and say look i've
tried everything so i would escalate
through your regular channels meetings
whatever forums but sometimes there's an
exact review where you say i'm blocked
this thing is red calling yourself red
is hard
but sometimes it gets the job done of
people saying oh okay you know i should
pay attention to this
the money one is harder right the money
one is always this is this huge problem
across the industry where you know um
you're never gonna have enough is that's
my experience no matter how much i have
to distribute to my team it's never
enough uh but again i think highlighting
it and you know sometimes
really making a case for this person
left because they had this much you
don't have an offer outside i don't want
these other people to leave so i need
xyz money so sometimes you've got to use
that data which we don't want to use
sometimes but
use that data like you know again put
your neck out for your team
uh because you will need to
those are excellent answers i've got the
last question to the exit question from
one of the
youtube viewers raja asks is there an
approach to fall that helps make the job
at hand fun and i'm going to interpret
that both as your job as an engineering
leader and also
making
the
jobs of your team
enjoyable fun for them
i'll say two things to this one i rarely
stay in jobs that are not fun there are
enough jobs out there
go find one that you truly care about
right be passionate about it because you
know we have a we
we work so many hours in a day that if
you're doing something that's not fun
i i wouldn't do it um
and trust me there will be other jobs
that pay you as much that will be fun so
don't you know
focus and figure it out you'll get there
uh and the second question is how to
make the team's job fun i think of it
the same way look all our jobs there's a
certain amount of what i call run the
business you have to go do those things
they may not be the most exciting you've
got to go do them
and you know you use the rest of your
time to go do innovation to go do cool
things whatever drives you right figure
out what drives your team and for me
it's i found that there's a set of folks
on the team who really want to be
empowered they want to go you know we
talked about skunk works projects
earlier to it it's like go find what
motivates
each person if possible and go find
wrong find things for them one person
may want a skunk works uh another person
may say you know what i really want
because of this phase of my life right
now is i really need every friday
afternoon off find a way to give them
that right it's not the same answer for
each person remember that and make that
happen for your team and and you know
you'll be a good leader
right because everybody's idea of fun is
different also like you said
some people have
find fun in solving
problems that no one else can solve and
some people find fun in
you know getting that feedback from the
customer that said you really helped me
with the problem so it it's like you
said each individual has their own
motivations this has been a
really wonderful session of it all i'm
going to apologize to
everyone
for the technical difficulties
especially with my audio
um
i
really
am not sure what the problem was but
i hope you've been uh born with us
through this
and we appreciate your being here
i'm going to thank
abital especially for being here i'm
going to do one
last
poll of the audience about continuous
learning and what it is
that you feel is
the most important thing or the most
desirable thing
for you individually
to
learn at this point what would you like
to learn what skills would you like to
add to your repertoire
and when would you like to do that so
i've got that poll up
and stuart i'm going to drop for my next
meeting thank you so much for having me
thanks to everybody
hope this was useful and thank you so
much for being so generous
thank you
okay
this is for the benefit people watching
on streaming these are the questions of
the topics and when you'd like to do it
i'm going to show the poll results with
people who are live on webex
and not surprising for this audience
but the
largest number of
responses was project minute
so i
will provide you with avatars linkedin
you can reach out to her on linkedin at
this address basically avatar
or you can just look her up
avatar aurora salesforce
in any search engine and i'll take you
to there
i want to mention that we do have a post
graduate program
in agile
so people who are interested in project
management and engineering management
this is a program in conjunction with
the university of massachusetts at
amherst
and one of the
interesting things about this program is
that
not only do you earn a certification
that you can actually transfer some of
these credits
get three credits that are transferable
to their master's program if you choose
to apply for
and are
admitted to that so
this is a great program both for
building your career and
for positioning you for further
education
and i think i've just placed
a link for more information into
the chat
and
we'll make sure that we have a
upcoming digital marketing master class
for
any of you who may be involved in
digital marketing or any of you who have
friends who are digital marketers
uh our math class matt bailey president
of sitelogic will be on thursday august
26th
and it will he'll do a deep dive into
some of the recent changes in
google search that
affect digital marketers directly
so we
hope so you join us there
check our website for more information
and do stay in touch with us through our
social channels
our handle is at simplylearn
and
you'll find us on facebook twitter
linkedin
we are global
we not only have offices in the united
states india but also singapore oops
sorry
and
we
support learners worldwide
so
we hope to see you at future webinars
and welcome you into the simply learn
learning community
again thank you so much for your
patience for staying with us and
as i said we will be sending out a
follow-up email with a link to this
recording
uh
so if you have been through the entire
webinar today we'll also receive
in a separate email over the weekend
a certificate
proof of attendance
and
that concludes webinar today
you